oh no no no not you again all right
folks
Doctor Who time so let's talk about some
great villains some great one-time
villains who should never be brought
back and I'm sticking this with modern
era
I'm not incorporating classic into this
list as I get more caught up on classic
maybe I'll do a classic version of this
in the future for you know villains to
not ever bring back but I mean I think
there's a lot more options there for
that in any case this list is going to
be about villains who were not recurring
villains appeared in only one story a
story and reminder for me two partners
count us one story and I don't think
they should ever be brought back for
various reasons and I will explain them
as I go now even though I am gonna be
doing a countdown I've got five of these
they're not actually in any order I'm
not building to a number one cuz I
couldn't think of a criteria to rank
these so I'm just gonna go through them
so I'll be counting them down but it's
not in in any kind of actual order so
number five the flood right now I know
I'm gonna get pushed back on a fair
amount of these from people because I
know from comments that people have been
like oh they should bring back this and
this this is one of them the flood was
the name given to the water infection in
waters of Mars and there's a number of
reasons why I don't want to see the
flood brought back part of it is and I
do have to cop to this
I think the floods a little overrated
because it's basically a zombie analogue
with infected one or a set of infected
blood so I'm not as enamored with the
flood as a lot of people are but I am
readily
grant that they are effective in that
story even though the type of thing that
they are doesn't have as much appeal for
me so the reason I don't I don't see
there to be much benefit of bringing
back the flood Indians a lot of these
things are going to keep occurring as I
talk about these is you have to look at
what can be done and what do you gain
versus what do you lose and what I mean
by that is whenever you bring something
like this back you demystify it a little
bit and I think a good go-to example is
the weeping angels now the subsequent
appearances of the weeping angels we're
actually pretty solid but let's be
honest they were never as scary again
being brought back because they couldn't
be because you only knew enough to get
it to get through that story but when
you bring a villain back and something
like the flood yeah you have to get more
information because if you don't then
all then really your only option is to
completely retread what you did last
time and what is there to to do then
what's the point all you've done is is
give diminishing returns because you're
just revisiting or you're adopting the
the slasher franchise model oh we'll
just do the same thing again so that
shouldn't be an option with any of these
but where is there really to go with the
flood I mean they have to stay on Mars
because if the whole concept is a single
drop gets in water anywhere on earth and
then it affects the whole planet well
you can't realistically prevent that so
they can't ever come to earth and you do
have to kind of limit them to - mud - to
being on Mars but I mean what is there
to do another colony gets up it gets on
Mars there's another breakout we go
through the whole thing again
alternately I'm sure some people would
say well you know you can do a prequel
because the doctor says that the Ice
Warriors froze this thing and that's
true but then you've got a predetermined
ending so I'll say that maybe if they
could find a twist on how to do that
that isn't just and at the end they
managed to freeze it which is what we
already know happen
from the background that mean that's
always the problem with prequels that
are filling in something to a point we
already know generally when prequels
work it's when it's you know we're
dealing with a chunk of time where oh
boy
anything's gonna happen there what did
let's watch but then when it's got a
predetermined outcome I don't see a lot
of value in that so I I don't think the
story possibilities that the flood
offers are enough to have them worth
bringing back number four
the family of blood one of my absolute
favorite one-time villains they are
astounding now I'm gonna caveat this
because I would say there is a
possibility of bringing back the family
of blood but you can't do them as
villains again because the doctor
trounced them so completely and that was
part of the whole thing with the
punishment you gave them is you realize
half the reason he was running from them
it was a mercy because if he stopped and
faced them he was gonna do horrible
things to them and they didn't stand a
chance and that's what happened so we
already know that they can't actually
take on the doctor we know that by the
end of their story so they they don't
work as a threat to try and bring them
back as that maybe if you were to have
some reason and be really hard to come
up with a reason that wasn't super
contrived that the doctor would want or
need the assistance of some or any of
these people the most obvious candidate
would be the daughter daughter of my
sister of mine however you want to think
of her as because it was actually
implied in the ending narration there
that maybe the doctor would let her out
someday we've got a problem in that I
would think she's probably not supposed
to age but obviously that actress would
have severely aged out so we'll have to
recast it was long enough ago that
probably not the end of the world to do
that but again I think it's very hard
especially with how much time has passed
to come up with a reason to bring them
back that could possibly live up to the
hype that's part of the problem with
some of these if it's been a really long
time since the last time we saw them
that creates an inherent build-up that
makes it all the harder for these things
to deliver on I think the family of
blood suffers from that possibly more
than any of the others that I've got on
this list number three this is what I
see brought up a lot and I don't get it
the Vashta Nerada I don't get why people
want the Bosch to Nerada back now the
bastion of Nerada are the shadows that
eat people from the two pod or has the
library force of the day and I love that
story I know it's so good and the
rationale nerado are great in it but the
first thing to realize is they're not
really I mean they're the they're the
they're functionally they are the
villains of the story and I do consider
them as such but they're not Doctor Who
villains in the traditional sense
they're not invaders they are incredibly
dangerous but as far as they're
concerned they're defending their own
territory so you can't have them you
know going out and becoming a problem
somewhere else the only reason it
happened to the library and you know it
doesn't happen anywhere else is that you
know the their force got ground and
pulped and bound into these books and
then the spores released in there they
are so you can't really do an invasion
story because the number of situations
in which that sort of scenario would
happen again it'd just be really
contrived and repetitive so then your
only option is to have the doctor happen
to land somewhere where the Vashta
Nerada already are and then what can you
do with them I mean from what we could
tell the bastard Narada were basically a
hive mind so if it's a hive mind only
eat it only interested in feeding and
protecting its own territory what is
there to do besides where people -
already did and what they already did
was brilliant the two shadows was
brilliant that the going dark and and
and all that stuff the you know the the
ghosts on the on the thing that was
great all that was great but if you do
it again you devalue it and I don't know
what else there is to be done with these
it's it's a bit it's a bit like frankly
it's like the alien from the aliens
franchise and yes I know they made
sequels including a real good one hope
they'll make a comparison in a second
but you know it's it's just this thing
that if you encounter it you're in a lot
of trouble so all you can do is
encounter a heck of a lot more of it
except this doesn't scale up the way
that aliens aliens did because we
already encountered a massive swarm of
it and if you do something like have a
Vashta Nerada queen or what-have-you
everyone will just go oh you're ripping
off aliens and it takes you out of it
it's not as good so I see this one
brought up a lot and as effective as the
best urner outer are I don't see what
the story possibilities are for them
other than just oh we landed in a place
where they are boy this is a pain in the
butt and I don't I don't think you gain
anything from that and I think you lose
some of the value that they had when you
do that because I think more possibly
more than any of the others because
there is no the the collective
intelligence that we understand of this
thing is limited ish at least in terms
of its desires and its goals what can
you do with that not much
I don't think number two the Beast now
impossible planet and Satan bit love
these things love what I mean I love
most of these things that I'm talking
about and as far as a character who
would have reason to be brought back and
come into the story again and a you know
cause a heck of a lot of trouble what he
wants you know he can he could
theoretically show up any number of
places cause all kinds of damage the
problem with this one is just the way
that the story ended which is an
unsurvivable scenario you know the the
both the body and the both the physical
form of the beast and the body which his
mind was possessing fell into a black
hole even if you want to tell me that
the Beast is such a creature that that
wouldn't kill him he still can't really
get out of that and I will now cop to
the fact that a yes a number of Doctor
Who villains have escaped definitive
deaths before primarily I would say
Davros and the master are the big ones
but I would say we don't need another
doctor who villain like that we don't
need another one where when we see them
quote-unquote die we go yeah right
when's he coming back
we don't two's enough I mean under other
circumstances if the master and Davros
weren't such good characters I would
argue too as too many I'm just not a fan
of that kind of thing if you're gonna
kill somebody and like be like oh no we
made it please stick to it and that's
kind of what I want for the beast and
the other thing is I worried that if
they were to ever bring the beast back
whether it be the physical body or the
mind or both that they'd have to answer
more questions about yet what it is and
where it comes from and I definitely
don't want that I love I think that
story hit the perfect balance of
ambiguity in terms of heavily implying
what it is but also giving the seeds of
doubt and the doctor having to admit he
does not know what he just thought and
I'd like that I like the the sort of
existential drag it puts on the doctor
that he not only did did he
I mean the doctor gets excited when when
he lands somewhere in some is you're on
that you just know if I ooh something
new but usually by the end of those
situations he understands what it was he
landed in I think the situations in
which the doctor comes away still not
really knowing what it was that happened
whether he could help or not those are
few and far between almost non-existent
and I kind of want to preserve the one
major instance that I am aware of where
that happened
and like I keep saying bringing the the
beast back is gonna dilute him because a
big part of what was epic about that
story was also the location the
impossible planet and I think moving the
Beast to anywhere else any you know
location that's not as hazardous that's
not as unique just will he'll lose
impact he'll lose vitality and he won't
be as good and finally number one the
midnight entity midnight is a brilliant
episode with a brilliantly realized
bizarre antagonist that I never ever
want to see again
I said with the Beast I couldn't think
of another one Midnight's the other one
Midnight's the other one where the
doctor doesn't know what just happened
doesn't know what it wanted doesn't know
what its goal was doesn't know if it was
malicious or just trying to survive and
he can't he will he will never know it
was the one time that the doctors
especially the Tenth Doctor superpower
of being able to talk his way out of
through you know whatever situation he's
in was used against him and I think that
standing as a singular shaking
experience for him is important in
addition to the fact that much like the
beast you can't bring it back without at
the very least explaining how it came
back and I don't see how you explain how
it came back without explaining more of
what it is and I don't want to know I
don't ever want to know I've seen some
insane fan theories about what people
think it is and you know if you have one
cool fine you know have your head Canon
that's lovely but like I don't I don't
have a theory what it is I don't want to
know there's stuff out there that we
cannot understand and we might encounter
it
interact with it but we'll never
understand it
in the midnight entity falls under that
and I love that and again also a bit
like the Beast a big part of David like
this was a villain that was designed to
work in a very specific scenario that
you can't just repeat the scenario
because then you're just repeating and
if you put that entity in that villain
in any other scenario can they possibly
work as well I doubt it I don't think so
because it was very custom built for the
story that it was in and the mystery and
the unknown of it is such a huge part of
what makes it so good I mean we call it
the midnight entity by default we don't
even have a name for this thing that's
perfect
no more information I don't ever want to
see it come back I don't want to ever
see something that gets hinted at will
later become the midnight entity not
don't ever want to know because it was
just this thing that was terrifying
let it stay that so that's my list of
five fantastic Doctor Who villains of
the modern era that I don't ever want to
see you again so what are your thoughts
what are some great one-time villains
that you think need to remain is
one-time villains or what are some
villains that have become recurring that
you think maybe should have only been
left at one appearance whatever your
thoughts aren't anything related to what
I just said drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's a
whole bunch of stuff you can do let such
as like and subscribe and support me on
patreon there's buttons and there's
links they take you places and they do
things check them out so remember folks
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]